the Joe Rogan experience like when I'm
around little girls like my daughter and
her friends and they're all like talking
about you like sometimes like they have
a birthday party and so does like 1012
kids at the house they're all talking
[ __ ] to each other right and you get to
just hover and listen it's like the
thing and they're talking about like
some boy at school who's always a boy
yeah so some door that picks his buddy
Cheers and he's so he's always trying to
be funny so mean you know and one of
them really like how old is she again 11
yeah that's yeah that's that's there
that's that's the that's the age when
the boys are starting to show the signs
of being like we're all getting hormones
yeah the boys would knock on the door
hey drama King a lot yeah this is the
government we're just gonna let you know
that the neighborhood is gonna be
changing radically over the next couple
years would just suggest you be careful
things are moving a newfound powers yeah
boners boners are coming boners are on
the way the flight of the boner have you
prepared for your boner anyone no one
even tells you what's going on all
sudden you got a hard-on like what is
how about that day on the bus when you
get a boner on the bus holy [ __ ] this is
your day up my friend John Dudley calls
them bumpy road boners bumpy bone about
when you're on a car that's bouncing
around yeah
somehow or another dudes get boners
sometimes because you're probably you
know it is it's probably the pressure on
your prostates activating your dick to
get [ __ ] you started and also you're
on the way home and you're you might
catch a glimpse of you know Natalie
who's got the tits already who's too too
young start to get hard as [ __ ] you miss
that one girl who's 13 with giant double
D's that was my dad like the house she
was stacked when we were kids
what happens there I used to I used to
miss a bus stop seriously sometimes I'd
miss a stop before my day if I had a
hard-on and I could've afraid to get off
the bus with a boner
even though you tuck it up you know you
tuck it up in your pants and I was
always afraid so I'd miss a stop or two
sometimes if I got a heart on the way
home wow I'd be so nervous and walk home
[ __ ] that yeah I'd rather go flaccid
you'd talk yourself out of it I'd have a
friend slap me and if I start fighting
with a friend yeah if you start fighting
with another dude friend your dick goes
right into your life it doesn't well
then you got a whole nother thing going
on then you get a new thing yeah Wow I
got a new thing now yeah I mean imagine
if you had to go through that all again
though and didn't know anything
like that's if the torture I've seen
like I mean I only understand boys like
because I've never been a girl but
the going through like being 10 11 12
going through school all the social
things not knowing [ __ ] yeah you're a
boy yeah it's so confusing like it sucks
once you finally become a man you don't
have to do that anymore you can just be
at peace in your own skins like oh
imagine going through all that stuff
again no I had now hiding jerking off to
like like you're like a [ __ ] you look
at me like did you don't know what
you're doing the bathroom for 20 minutes
in a magazine you're a little ninja
jerky or a jerk-off ninja now I and now
I kind of hope my neighbors see me you
know it's kind of part of the part of
the allure I jerk off in my living room
sometimes to do hope and they walk by
walking their dog wave hug thing if they
see you jerking off in your house I
think you can get in real big trouble I
think a guy got in trouble jerking off
in his house with the windows up shut up
your private he's pretty property no no
no I think because you could see into
this guy's house and he was beating off
they they came and got him why cuz there
was kids or something like that remember
what the story was but it was a big deal
or people like hey the guy's just
jerking off inside his own house like
what is the big goddamn deal yeah okay
had the door open for the window open or
something like that guy who's out there
jerking off at the front door pushing
open letting in the breeze of course
there is yeah I bet people go to hotels
and then they open up the door and they
stuff a wedge on the door and start
[ __ ] and then let everybody walk by a
watch yeah leave the door open that's
Vegas especially before cellphones all
these [ __ ] goddamn tattle-tale
cellphones and his dirty cameras back
then people just I probably I bet that
was a common thing just [ __ ] with the
door open yeah like Hells Angels they
all took over a hotel Sawa wow those
guys [ __ ] with that door wide open they
[ __ ] in this tree I'm sure they [ __ ]
at the bar and by exactly that
voyeuristic thing never was like a thing
from a know some people like [ __ ] in
public cause I think it's hot to maybe
get caught
never never got me it was always like my
I don't [ __ ] why do I want to know
that someone's watching me
that's creepy if you get arrested you
get weird charges too like if you [ __ ]
someone in public in some places they'll
hit you with like a sex offender charge
yeah because it's exposure
yeah dude I had
like that in college I had urinating in
public I had to fight a public exposure
charge yeah that's a real problem
because that's a piss and goddamn thing
that every man understands and that's a
little game they're playing yeah how's a
dirty game you caught a guy taking a
leak and you're saying that's public
exposure look he shouldn't have been
taking a leak outside maybe but
everybody's done it so stop had to piss
yeah when guys have to piss and there's
nothing around they piss in alleys
anyone doing that since the beginning of
time you're right so for some [ __ ]
guy to pretend that that's is like
robbing a house or trying to kidnap a
kid right like that's not a sex offender
no that's a guy that @p yeah but I had
to be in a room and I brought in a in
one of those rooms with people that did
expose himself and I was like nothing
like these dudes man I'm nothing like
these [ __ ] guys I was pissing outside
little bar walking if you pissed your
pants I should've know if you pissed
your pants they can't say [ __ ] all right
I know it's not at least hey you pissed
your pants in public though yeah but I
have my pants on you know it's still you
know have you seen these in Europe
they've talked about bringing them some
places in America I think what they have
you stand-in there in jerk off side no
they have opened urinals just like in
the middle of the street all those dudes
jerking off in there for sure
[Applause]